Beijing has issued a travel warning for
the United States saying Chinese
citizens should fully assess the risks
of traveling to the US given recent
shootings the warning comes a stray
tensions between the world's two biggest
economies rise on Monday Beijing warned
Chinese students of risks associated
with studying in the US now it's talking
of Chinese citizens being harassed by US
immigration officers while entering the
country China's foreign ministry also
accuses the u.s. of waging economic war
against China to prevent its rise to
power
it says Washington has constantly
changed demands and made reckless
allegations over the weekend Beijing
signaled a willingness to negotiate but
stressed it did not fear a trade war
with the US it is a complete twisting
and fabrication of the truth for the
u.s. to accuse China of going back on it
Straight Talk commitments both sides
have pummeled each other with hundreds
of billions of dollars in punitive
tariffs the US has also blacklisted
China's telecoms champion who our way
Beijing responded by announcing its own
intention to make a list of foreign
companies which it considers quote
unreliable it also threatened to limit
access to its rare earth exports China
is the world's largest exporter of the
minerals essential for making smart
phones TVs and other high-tech products
and for more let's bring in our
financial market corn correspondent
corner at Busan and there he is Corner
at this trade spot trade war keeps
taking on new dimensions now Beijing
issuing a travel warning how worried
should the u.s. be well I think this is
really worrying a piece of news not so
much because you know tourism from China
would be a very important factor for the
economy in the US but this illustrates
that the conflict between China and the
u.s. is not limited to some unfriendly
wording on the top political level it
now really has arrived on the level of
everyday lives we should not forget
there are thousands of Chinese
scientists doing research at
universities in the US
thousands of Chinese Chinese citizens
are studying at US universities and this
travel ban by the Chinese now is really
the perfect tool to aggravate the
situation and you know to make it worse
at least in terms of sentiment and
propaganda okay so it it's going to be
quite interesting to see US Secretary
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin
meeting his counterpart in China the
governor of the People's Bank of China
this weekend at the g20 finance leaders
summit is that a chance to melt the ice
you know Monica in former times I would
have said yes institutions like the g20
were initiated to melt the ice between
nations to smooth the way how they
operate together but even if some of the
members of the Trump administration
sometime come out with statements giving
hope that you know the government wants
to cooperate the things that the
President himself says sound very
differently he permanently permanently
keeps disrupting things and that is
throwing sand in the works of
institutions like the g20
all right Conrad Busan there in
Frankfurt thank you so much